j'accueille olivier de kersauson
quand bonne compagnie en boule la hâte à
2 pts à deux mètres la halle à un check
côté là nanard et kersaux à 8 mois qui
l'a pas vu une femme et c'est normal il
était sur la mer alors on est très
heureux de vous avoir ce soir olivier
pour vous rendre hommage pour votre
double exploit double exploit le 27
avril donc j'ai pulvérisé le record de
la traversée du pacifique
d'est en ouest de san francisco donc aux
usa à yokohama au japon
j'ai battu le record de steve fossett
quitté vieux de dix ans vous l'avait
amélioré de cinq jours premier record
donc dans un sens et dans l'autre sens
records le 12 juin d'une partie de yo
hamas d'arriver à san francisco le
faisait battu le record de bruno peyron
franchement si les mecs qui vous avait
enterré dillon avait de la ressource un
nom mais surtout c'est des parcours
intéressants de paco matéo logiquement
très pointue très hasardeuse
des très difficile pour tous c'est
épouvantable 1 le temps aux jeunes a
fait douze jours de tunnels un jour
brume 12 degrés sur 8 et 12 degrés pas
de vent et une mer complètement cassée
par un côté d'un porte jamais journée de
glisse la même journée marc anga même
journée le terrible ça pourrait être
pire
ouais le bien serait pas bête le record
en tous les cas même et là on était
bloqués avec quatre jours d'avancé
débloque un anticyclone on pouvait pas
faire le tour la météo du pacifique
enfin quand on atlantique c'est très
simple on le voit bien et anticyclone
des açores et dépression sans de la
mairie qu'elle arrive sur et si
l'angleterre ou l'espagne pacifique il
ya toujours 3 4 des pressions et rocades
anticyclone et on sait pas où on la même
dépression avance monte dans le nord
repart dans en direction opposée
les prédictions change tous les six
heures dans les nouvelles qu'on a sur la
météo on vous dit qu'à taylor ça va
faire ça six heures plus tard savoir
qu'elle peut devenir chèvre
le parcours était tordu c'est pas des
parcours rapide
on n'a pas été dit au final je vais
gagner traités passés avant n'était pas
évident du tout du tout c'est génial
trouve pas quand même kersauson moi je
trouve que je sais pas quels jeux vous
allez mais c'est incroyable quand même à
votre âge il a toujours des records 36
ans ariel c'est pour ça on va regarder à
quoi ça ressemblait ce coupé regarder
votre caméra et dire magnéto richard
magnéto richard